good morning Hank it's Monday sorry
about the hoarseness but the tiny
chickens have migrated down into my
throat Hank you'll notice that I'm
apologizing to you for my husky voice
but I am not apologizing to our female
viewers to them I say you're welcome
okay get important nerdfighteria news
name master Tom is conscious he's been
able to speak to his family but he still
has a long way to go in his recovery and
we're going to be there with him as a
community on that entire journey
nerdfighters you can go to the Ning to
see a letter from Tom's family about how
much they appreciate your letters keep
those letters coming to Ning Master Tom
at gmail.com and if you want to
participate in a collab video for Tom
you can click here on my hand so make
more on Tom in a minute but yesterday I
was watching the closing ceremonies at
the Olympic Games and it was just
getting to the awesome part the part
with giant inflatable beavers off topic
but someone should write a novel called
giant inflatable beavers in your pants
and as I was watching those giant
inflatable beavers there was suddenly a
Bob Costas voice over and he was like
and now time for the marriage Ref which
if you don't live in America is a new
television show it's the closing
ceremonies of Jerry Seinfeld's career
all right Hank because I know you didn't
see the show I'm gonna summarize it for
you in 20 seconds a married couple who
are the kind of people who desire to be
on reality shows and therefore unlikable
have a disagreement let's say one of
them wants to stuff their dead dog and
the other wants to bury it the couple
introduces us to their disagreement
three Hollywood celebrities make some
jokes and then decide the winner of the
argument spoiler alert the dog gets
buried egg aside from being
astonishingly unfunny the married Rev is
also profoundly insulting to Americans
it's condescending aggressively
anti-intellectual and wrongly supposes
that Americans want advice from
celebrities celebrities we don't want
your advice we want your breakups and
your nipple slips that's not why I'm
shouting myself hoarse about the
marriage Ref though Hank here's my
problem
jeff zucker the head of NBC Universal
could you look any do here oh yeah he
could is fond of saying and interviews
that YouTube is great for looking at
pictures of squirrels on trampolines in
fact he has said advertisers have been
clear they don't want their ads next to
cats on skateboards dude you're spending
millions of dollars on programming about
dog taxidermy one could argue that your
house is not perfectly equipped for
stone throwing you know what Jeff Zucker
you're right
advertisers find you more attractive
than they find
me although that might change when they
hear my husky voice but the difference
between NBC and nerdfighteria is that
nerdfighteria is not in the advertiser
fellating business we're in the pond
sand filter business and the Haitian
relief business and the funny Pizza
shirt business available to Wednesday
lincoln.the do we do and our biggest
business of all is taking care of each
other I love nerdfighteria because it's
a place for people who have felt on the
outside looking in to be on the inside
of something awesome and important and
Hank I've never loved nerdfighteria more
than in the last few days seeing
hundreds of emails come to Tom and his
family wishing them well jeff zucker
nerdfighteria may be nothing but a
youtube based community but we are more
real than all your reality shows
combined correct me if I'm mistaken but
I don't see any cats and I don't see any
skateboards which you might have noticed
if you didn't have your head so far up
the ass of a gigantic inflatable beaver
jeff zucker i'll see you when you apply
for a job as head of nerdfighteria
programming in five years Hank I'll see
you on Wednesday